sondern scheiße ist wirklich überall
drin das ist sie keine ahnung warum aber
alter generationen notgeil hände übers
web threats willkommen bei bio- und ja
ich weiß mittlerweile eigentlich der
grammatikalisch richtiger wenn ich zu
einem neuen video sagen würde aber wir
sind hier nicht schule von daher bleibt
das natürlich so ich meine hat jetzt für
macht sich machen also schon gesagt und
warum sollte das jetzt ändern und
deswegen und schon ganz viel spaß mit
dem video
heute ist das thema wie wird man sowieso
richtig fame und ja also es gibt ja
sämtliche social networks instagram
youtube facebook spam und die sind diese
ganze scheiße und es gibt so viele
fernmelde menschen und die frage sich
dann alle macht wie wie werde ich daheim
kipper bei google ein
wie werde ich auf links vom sondern wenn
ihr schon eigene wie werde ich auch
kommt schon wie werde ich auf youtube
filmen wie werde ich auch in zukunft das
ist alles so schön aufgereiht ja und
dann habe ich mir gedacht ja kommen an
hilfst du diesen ganzen verein menschen
noch mal wie es da draußen so gibt paar
tipps von mir also ich will endlich
sagen dass ich filmen aber ich kenne
mich da nicht gut aus niemand so richtig
fällen wird und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß wenn es euch gefällt dass er
nach oben instagram ist in der video
beschreibung snapshot auch endlich da
auf jeden fall das ist jetzt kein scherz
als wegbeschreibung und lang alle meine
gedanken ja ich weiß jetzt auch gar
nicht so genau wo ich jetzt wirklich
anfangen soll wenn ich habe so viele
gute tipps für euch und ich würde sagen
wir fangen ganz simpel mit mit youtube
anfang ganz simpel fange mit youtube an
ok
mir fällt da zurzeit so ein ganz
bestimmter parteien und da frage ich
mich so manchmal hat jetzt irgendwie
ihre tastatur fehler im youtube also
philipp ist irgendwie das team und ich
weiß es nicht
auf jeden fall kennedy vielleicht ich
weiß nicht will auch gar keine namen
sagen es gibt bestimmt auch mehrere
er sollte aber die hat wirklich ist
immer auf meiner startseite das sind
einfach zu videos die sind total und
aussagekräftig und da fehlt doch so 5
prozent steigerung dann könnte das auf
youtube laden das wenn überhaupt nicht
auf ich meine das heißt wenn ihr jetzt
weiblich sein und denkt ja ich will so
richtig fällen werden geht einfach zum
schönheitschirurgen habt euch so ein
bisschen silikon daran ihr wisst schon
was ich meine und lasse es auf youtube
hoch aber mit möglichst viel haut zeigen
weil das ist immer wichtig ich weiß auch
nicht warum man kriegt so was und wie
youtube so viele klicks ich meine geht
doch einfach wenn ihr so notwehr seien
auch irgendwelche anderen plattformen
dann hätten wir das ja doch ein tipp das
mache ich auch manchmal ich gebe es auch
zu ja und zwar deshalb mails klatsch
einmal irgendwelche frauen auf das habe
ich glaube ich auch schon mal gesagt
dass das kriegt immer mehr klicks als
wenn man keine frauen auf klatsch und
zwar so frauen wie ihr wisst schon was
ich meine ok lassen was mal bis dahin so
stehen und ich würde sagen dass das war
auch so sachen viele von euch wissen
dass wahrscheinlich schon wie man das so
macht das auch schon mal ein paar videos
zu die himbeer gemacht hat wo er das so
schön erklärt hat auf jeden fall gibt es
natürlich auch noch andere plattform ich
würde sagen wir machen wir weiter mit
ascap m zum beispiel ich habe mir
letztens auch wieder hats gefallen
gemacht und das ist wirklich praktisch
ein paar fragen zu beantworten
auch wenn sich jemand nicht traut meiner
frage zu stellen kann man da anonym
beleidigen warum auch nicht aber ich
habe es wirklich den link wenn ich auch
mal in der video beschreibung von benny
bock habt das hättet mich da ein
bisschen oder so ist kein ding könnt ihr
gerne machen und ich habe mir da auch so
das ziel gesetzt hier wirst du so
richtig fällen aber nie machst du das am
bist ja aber erstmal muss man natürlich
seine seite so ein bisschen aufmischen
und wie macht man das am besten ganz
einfach man geht auf facebook sucht sich
eben welche facebook-seiten raus sie
irgendwelche bilder posten die gut
ankommen vielleicht eins mit 50.000
likes und dann hat man eine frage
gestellt bekommen zum beispiel warum ist
seine unterhose rot und dann postet mal
einfach als antwort dieses bild dahin
und das kriegt dann wenn ihr glück habt
5000 reiki ganz ehrlich mit glück dass
vielleicht doch nicht so viel zu tun ihr
könnt oder ihnen müssen eigentlich
müsste einfach gehen media zeiten gehen
bleibt ja alles
euch dann sah der viel von mir gesagt
vielleicht dann geht das auch oder ihr
könnt also von wegen ja schaut doch mal
bei mir vorbei ins tor fand ich auch ab
und zu denke ich mir also was ist denn
los mit euch ach ja irgendwelche fast
nackt bilder forst ausfahrt ist auch mal
gut kommt auch mal gut an oder immer so
diese ganzen mädchen nicht komplett hier
in staatssäckel voll mit irgendwelchen
bauchfreien links punkt hallo und wiba
story im irak stehen blieben bei diesem
mädchen die post an irgendwelche bilder
hängt also so formen vom spielern ihr
t-shirt hoch dass man ihren bauch sieht
das hat dann auch mal so 200 live ein
warum nicht ich versuche das auch mal
auf das sollte auf jeden fall likes
kriegen so stehen die wahrscheinlich vom
vieldeutigkeit laut nein spaß sollte ich
meine es ist alles gar nicht so ganz auf
jeden fall machen wir weiter mit
instagram das auch noch in plattform
natürlich es gibt ganz normale leute ja
auch viele follower vielleicht
irgendwelche youtuber trotzdem lieber
oder so hat viele follower ja nee das
war jetzt ernst gemeint also dass der
biber ist doch voll war
ich weiß es nicht wenn es da noch von
prominenten gibt aber es gibt diese
ganzen komischen wandels die eigentlich
keiner kennt also ich kenne ihn nicht
aber die haben bei instagram so 150
tausend follower weil irgendwelche
notgeil 40 jeden männer folgen oder
irgendwelche fitness geil 15 jährigen
mädchen die auch mal so werden wollten
verstehe ich so man will kraus moment
das geht ganz schnell so man geht
einfach hier auf sophie und guckt man
aber wie sowieso postet man sowas warum
und das hat dann 8000 like sondern
scheiße ist wirklich überall drin das
ist sie keine ahnung warum aber alter 11
generation notgeil ja gut so viel darf
ich würde mich auch gar nicht weiter
drüber aufregen
auf jeden fall ja ich weiß nicht ich
kann auch keine ahnung ob ich der
einzige
ja so denken und ob ich jetzt hier mega
die heckwelle kriege weil alle von euch
solchen mädchen frauen folgen so welche
seiten auf facebook das ist jetzt
wirklich mal ein richtig guter tipp von
mir
ich meine ich kann nicht bei facebook
letztlich wirklich aus ich bin auch
nicht wirklich aktiv ich hab zwar eine
seite die es auch in der mitte
bestattung check ist auf jeden ablenken
und so seien auf jeden fall was mir dazu
aufgefallen ist wie man halt von so ein
video hochladen kann man sucht sich eben
was lustiges aus reutlingen und tanz
oder so und dann macht man das nach oder
versucht sie irgendwie kassel stamme aus
und kommentiert die so richtig blöd oder
man regt sich darüber auf dass alle
wieder posten dass das schöne wetter so
schön ist oder man regt sich darüber auf
dass alle pause das schöne wetter so wie
scheiße ist
auch wenn das gerade keinen sinn ergeben
hat ohne schweiß und ich habe überhaupt
keine ahnung wie dieses video an kommen
wird ich bin einfach mega gespannt und
ich würde sagen wir falls euch gefallen
dass auf jeden fall noch nach oben da
bin ich schon mega freuen weil ich bin
ja noch fehler als diese ganzen
halbnackten frauen
und ansonsten will ich sagen instagram
nochmal in der haben seite ist auch
stressig alkohol auf jetzt hier auf der
linken seite geht es weiter mit meinem
letzten video das war dinge die man in
einer beziehung möglichst nicht tun
sollte und die auf der anderen seite
kommen hierzu keine abend lasst euch
überraschen mich hat es gefreut dieses
video für euch unten drehen zu dürfen
und ich sagte wir sehen uns mit
ich wollte es machen schick mir geholfen
meinen blog hat und bis jetzt das video
geschleudert